Henry Cavill may be making a return to a high-profile
franchise.
No, not that one.
The rumor-mongerers at We Got This Covered
are back with a new report that's too good
to believe, claiming that Henry Cavill, who
portrayed the villainous CIA turncoat August
Walker in Mission: Impossible Fallout, may
return for the next installment.
You may be wondering how this is possible.
Fans will remember that during Fallout's climax,
Ethan Hunt was forced to chased down Walker
in a commandeered helicopter in order to prevent
the latter from putting into motion a plan
to contaminate a massive portion of the world's
water supply with stolen nuclear weapons.
After a stunningly shot, Cruise-endangering
aerial chase, Hunt forces Walker to crash-land
by... well, just straight-up crashing into
him, then engages the villain in fisticuffs
on a treacherous, snowy mountainside.
Of course, the ever-resourceful Hunt finds
an exceedingly cinematic way to dispatch his
nemesis, dropping one of the helicopters'
winch hooks on him and crushing him to death.
The detonators are secured, the world's water
supply is safe, and as for Walker well, he's
just super-dead.
If you're thinking it seems like Fallout's
ending would preclude a return to the role
of Walker by Cavill, well, we're right there
with you.
So, how would it happen?
A dream sequence?
Perhaps a flashback?
Maybe the as-yet untitled Mission: Impossible
7 will be a prequel?
Or perhaps August Walker was actually the
nefarious alter-ego of Superman, a guy whom
he bears a suspicious resemblance to, and
he was therefore able to simply shake off
getting a half-ton winch hook dropped on him?
In our humble opinion, the answer is none
of the above, because we're pretty sure that
this rumor is baloney for a couple of simple
reasons.
First: Cavill's character is, again, dead
as a doornail at the conclusion of Fallout.
Second: the mysterious "inside sources" are
literally the only ones reporting this, and
those sources sources that may well just be
"Reddit posts and Twitter" are often terribly,
embarrassingly wrong.
Sorry, but it's true.
"People actually fall for that."
Also, there's the fact that when it comes
to Mission: Impossible 7 and 8, which will
shoot back to back, very few details have
been made public.
We suppose it's possible that a hit-and-miss,
generally unreliable source could luck its
way into accurate information that exactly
zero reputable media outlets have yet caught
a whiff of.
But do we have any reason to believe it?
No, not really.
No, we're going to go ahead and peg this rumor
as "completely unfounded" and "probably total
bunk."
First and foremost, we are of the opinion
that Hayley Atwell improves anything she is
involved with, and the next two Mission: Impossible
movies will have precisely one more Hayley
Atwell than any of the previous films in the
franchise have had.
Star of the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
the late, great series Agent Carter, Atwell
is one of the more talented actresses working
today and she's already proven that she totally
has what it takes to be an action star.
Second, the ageless, apparently indestructible
Cruise is returning as Hunt, as is Rebecca
Ferguson, who has shined in the last three
Mission: Impossible pictures as Ilsa Faust,
the former British intelligence agent and
operative for the criminal organization known
as the Syndicate who is now firmly on the
side of Hunt and the IMF.
Her chemistry with Cruise has only grown more
potent during her tenure in the franchise,
and her return is most welcome.
Finally, writer/director Christopher McQuarrie
will be back to fill both roles on Mission:
Impossible 7 and 8, and this is a guy who
knows how to write for and direct Cruise perhaps
better than anyone in Hollywood.
He wrote and helmed 2012's Jack Reacher, turned
in an amazing screenplay for the time-twisting,
sci-fi Edge of Tomorrow, and has masterminded
the previous two Mission: Impossible movies,
which were among the series' best.
Yes, he also wrote The Mummy, the film that
both launched and sealed the doom of Universal's
Dark Universe franchise, but we can forgive
him for that.
Mission: Impossible has improbably proven
to be one of the best action franchises of
all time, starting off strong and seeming
to only get better as it keeps trucking along.
Personally, we can't wait for the seventh
and eighth installments to hit screens, and
when they do, we're pretty sure it'll be without
Cavill.
Cruise, though, seems to want to keep making
these movies until he's 80 and we have a feeling
he probably will, provided one of them doesn't
finally do him in.
Mission: Impossible 7 is slated for release
on July 23, 2021; Mission: Impossible 8 will
follow on August 5, 2022.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.